hello my name is jamil spain developer
advocate with the ibm cloud
as a technologist everyone has that
opportunity to build that first
large-scale application for me that's
been almost 14 years ago the first
challenge that i
encountered where i had to do this task
all by myself a single coder of one was
actually an online admissions
application
now doing that process which is way way
beyond any hello world
i had to actually have the opportunity
to put in business logic into the
application as i was developing it
well there's actually a term for that
and it's my topic for today
business rules
so what exactly are business rules if i
had to simplify this for you
let's just say that it is the everyday
logic
that gets
programmed into actual applications um
not to be confused with business
requirements which really that's the
output of what you're developing the
application for we can call it kind of
the success criteria so the business
rules are really the way you formulate
that business logic in
and it's usually done in many different
circumstances but let me pose a
situation for
how it came to be that you kind of kind
of work through now now when you think
about it in your existing applications
whereas when i approach that this is
generally how that design actually
occurred i started with application code
and at some point my immediate goal was
to get me over
to the actual data store of course
now at some point i am building
workflows algorithms as you may call it
particular patterns that i must follow
what happens when someone signs up what
happens
um when they want to register for a
class you know all these type of things
in my mind i was trying to picture how
do you symbolize those and how does it
work so i just take two arrows here but
i wanted to kind of formulate that there
are many many decisions and functions
and methods that must be programmed to
work
clearly
all my data is inside my database so i'm
doing a back and forth this can actually
be a two-way street here but what i
noticed and when i think about when i
first started development i really
attached
my logic into these individual flows so
here i may have other functions
that actually ran different logic and
they were just kind of all over the
place functions here functions there
kind of as i started to approach them or
another business requirement came up or
something i had to do that had to be a
part of this workflow i just kept
piggybacking and band-aiding onto
processes
all right and it kept on going kept on
going
and naturally when i had to make changes
or update or something evolved i had to
try to go back in and band-aid and let's
hope that there weren't two types of
similar operations that had to occur in
both these workflows i had two or more
places to kind of go here so this is
where exactly where it comes in
the context of where i'm talking to you
today is
formulate that into business rules so
you'll have a secondary engine
code classes some type of interface that
you want to kind of code into where
naturally a lot of your data flows in
through here
and then flows out
maybe to your database has that process
here and this gives you that one place
where you can start to formulate things
to have
one particular area that data has to
flow through and then this gets me back
to
why business rules are really important
so we said it's the everyday logic and
you can actually know that that's
symbolized by your
your your syntax that we usually do for
a lot of decision trees so you have your
what i like to call the ifs all right uh
so this would be expressing logic
and we said the
ifs
so that's the ifs of the thens
only
if else
and naturally i have other conditions
when something happens this should
happen and maybe
[Music]
i'll only do this particular piece of
logic if and only if
so you can tell it gets really
it's kind of your basic structures but
gives you a big formal way of kind of
working with that now you may say why
as i like to do with any technology or
as a technology anything i want to
implement i have to ask myself that
question
why do i actually want to do this there
are obvious benefits that i want to
spend my time in re-architecting the
application and as i started to work
through this video concept here i
actually thought about ways i could
improve my original design if i actually
went with this kind of architecture way
back then but let's talk through those
and they're very very important to cover
here
uh the first is efficiency
a definitely added point there
because
naturally you can always see there's
only one place i have to make changes
all right
and that really helps
with
anything that i want to kind of
assimilate and do i have one place to
make the code changes i also say for
consistency
they're definitely going to be a plus in
that area as well
naturally now with all these different
workflows you think about the context of
an application for an emissions from
maybe
any type of institution that has to
require an application for admissions is
you have many different departments i
have one consistent way to represent my
workflows
and i may have you know maybe for the
admission criteria
i may have better ways to give to the
scholarship committee to understand
how we make decisions on admission so it
gives you kind of a consistent process
that you can use to really help
formulate a
particular workflows
there as well
and then the last we have efficiency
we're going to be consistent
the complexity
so not increasing complexity but we have
a way to
definitely
decrease
complexity because now we have
a easy way to represent how we can take
a part of business workflow and break it
up into constraints and parts that you
know we can simulate it for how it
should work here and now we have a
template
that can actually be used for the next
business process and the next business
process and quietly this is really the
foundation of entering into um actual
automation and we'll get a lot about
that please check out the process mining
video we'll talk about how this this a
lot of these activities really parlay
you into that particular context here
but yeah definitely
obvious ways that you can kind of get
direct benefits out let's go back to the
logic here though
we mentioned some of the basic control
structures that works
but this also goes by there's a there's
even a discipline for classifying how
these rules apply now they can be
constraints
and think of constraints as things that
immediately happen i already know a
condition
that's there so i know things that i
want to do so we'll call that of uh a
yes criteria i met something so i can
immediately jump here
so for admissions do you have a certain
gpa yes we can go um there's you can
also do pre and post
conditions the what must happen when the
data comes in and out just to make sure
uh two conditions are set um
and things that flow from there um and
then uh there's other types of inference
we'll say
all right scribbled on in there we at
least got it in the word is inference
here and that's really uh based upon two
particular contexts here i can also say
whenever i have some facts that i know
that i can make decisions on for
instance um
um
you may i mentioned like a particular
gpa or certain sat scores i can make
different factors there and then we have
the things that we can calculate these
type of numerical facts or conditions
here
i'll just do a calc
and then those computational things can
actually allow to me to get to certain
facts
here as well i remember at one point we
were evaluating the applications i had
to build a workflow that helped with
evaluation
if you did this on your if you input it
this from your scoring your essay you
got this many points for a number of
activities gpa all those things so i
have certain facts that i can then make
decisions over to know you're in a final
group off of there just theorizing here
as well so we've kind of moved through
on how you kind of start out
and how you should have an architecture
to take
proper implementation of business rules
we know the logic that's applied in
different really different situations
that you can build a lot of the
workflows to gain these obvious benefits
just to bring it on home here let's talk
through a couple of use cases that
really i can kind of see besides this
that
can really be useful or for you to use
now the first i did mention here
i kind of gave that one away but we said
the first was definitely applications
now i'm not saying that every actual web
application project requires business
rules but we are talking
some of the large-scale applications
that you want to build definitely
anything that requires an application
you have ways that you can apply
definite criteria to work and also a lot
of these situations let's say in that
situation where we had the application i
was building i also had to prove how
applications were evaluated so for
regulations and compliance
you also can have a track record on how
you went through and made a decision you
know it wasn't just
um if these were just loose rules like
here
it has an opportunity that it could not
have gotten picked up or one particular
piece of code could not have done
the the particular constraint that we
wanted to apply but since everything
rinses through we have a great
opportunity to show how it was evaluated
and show that kind of check and balance
uh here
let's say also for e-commerce
so an e-com let's think about the
opportunity when you do purchases and
returns and throughout the pandemic we
know that we bought a lot of things
online have been numerous products that
have been ordered
we definitely always want to make sure
before we go back and return has it been
the 30 days has it been the 14 days and
most a lot of applications i've gone
through and used and returned products
you have to request the return
authorization it's merely going to ask
you when did you purchase this and so at
that first
iteration i have an opportunity to say
it's been
plus or minus
30 days or 14
and if i would like to that's a great
opportunity for me to go ahead and send
back a rejection sorry it's been past
that time here but definitely give you a
way to help evaluate different pieces
there
and also
think about purchasing there's a great
opportunity to
interact with other systems of inventory
moving inventory around we all know that
there's been a lot of inventory issues
as of yet that we've come through and
last but not least one that i love i
want you to definitely pay attention to
and i think this is great in today's
many of today's architectures here and
it's um the
all right scribble that out
personalization so a lot of these
engines everything is personal to you
and i love it when i actually go to
i get to browse the site i may be able
to come come back so let's say you have
the opportunity of new visitors and
returning
so if i'm a new visitor i have a great
opportunity to put you into my new
visitor workflow here are my featured
products that i want you to pay
attention to here are my deals the
specials that i have but let's say i'm a
returning user i'm just coming back to a
website this can be an opportunity to
show me what i've been looking at or to
correlate i actually personally love the
engine where i'm able to say
other people who are looking at this
they bought this maybe you should look
at these options as well because it's
all about diving deep into the
specifications and understanding what's
the option of why should i buy this over
that especially when it comes to
all the gadgets that i love here
so
we've done a lot today we talked about
business rules the logic the rules that
are required the obvious benefits that
you can use to really implement this
type of architecture and some use cases
that you can kind of immediately jump
out to you've always wanted to do this
with this is a formal
sturdy way of actually implementing this
type of logic in your application if you
have any questions please drop us a line
below
and if you want to see more videos like
this in the future please like and
subscribe